Що буде з медичною реформою після президентських виборів, після парламентських?
Говоримо з виконувачкою обов'язків міністра охорони здоров'я Уляною Супрун.
Пані Уляно, дякую, що знайшли час на інтерв’ю.
Новообраний президент Володимир Зеленський
після свого обрання і до цього критикував медичну реформу.
Чи є у вас з ним контакт зараз? Що можете сказати?
Коли є вибори, коли відбуваються вибори, то дуже часто
під час кампанії є вислови, які можливо,
не віддзеркалюють ті речі,
які відбудуться після виборі
Те, що були якісь вислови під час кампанії,
трохи змінилось після того, коли
від команди Зеленського ми почули,
що є підтримка реформ,
що вони б хотіли подивитись, як вони відбуваються,
дати якісь поради.
До вас зверталась вже команда Зеленського?
Це було через доктора Комаровського,
який написав дуже чітко,
що він підтримує хід реформ.
Є якісь можливі поради, які вони готові нам надати.
Ми готові презентувати зміни, які зараз відбуваються,
але наполягаємо на тому, що вони вже розпочаті,
що є вже другий етап, який розпочинається цього літа
і останній етап, який розпочинається від 2020 року щодо зміни фінансування.
Дивно, як на мене,
те що радник новообраного президента
звертається до вас через соціальні медіа,
через блог на "Українській правді", бо саме там він це написав.
Чому немає персонального зв’язку?
Вибори відбулись коли?
Тиждень тому...
Тиждень тому. Навіть неповний. Тиждень тому.
З часом вони будуть, як я розумію,
команда нового президента буде зустрічатись
з тими міністрами, тими інституціями,
щоб поспілкуватись з ними і дізнатись, що далі відбувається.
Тобто ризиків, що зі зміною глави держави
чи  навіть парламенту, пізніше восени,
зміниться стратегія  хід медичної реформи, ви не відчуваєте?
Дуже багато змін вже було зроблено.
Нові інституції, які існують і працюють.
Національна служба здоров'я або Національний центр громадського здоров'я,
який займається тим,
щоб ми залишились здоровими замість того, щоб хворіли.
Вони вже існують. Там працюють сотні людей,
вони вже програми свої втілили.
Є закон, який вимагає, щоб ми змінювали фінансування.
Є програма "доступні ліки",
є програми закупівлі ліків на державному рівні.
27,5 мільйонів українців вже обрали своїх сімейних лікарів.
25 тисяч лікарів вже є у новій системі і отримують
вдвічі і тричі зарплати, ніж колись вони мали на первинній ланці.
І я думаю, що ті всі зміни показують,
що хід реформ йде правильно. Будемо їх
продовжувати цей рік і наступний рік,
щоб знову всі українці мали доступ до якісних медичних послуг.
Пані Уляно, є відчуття,  що якісь певні саме реформи,
що вони під загрозою після того, як може змінитись команда?
У вас як у виконувачки обов'язків...
Зараз ми робимо трирічне планування бюджету
разом з міністерством фінансів із урядом Володимира Гройсмана.
І це трирічне планування.
Ми вставляємо в новий бюджет ті кошти, які будуть потрібні, щоб фінансувати
наступні зміни, які відбуваються.
Є закон, який був прийнятий Верховною Радою
ще у жовтні 2017 року, який вимагає,
щоб фінансування змінювалось і від першого січня 2020
все фінансування, яке йде на охорону здоров'я, крім військових,
йшло через Національну службу здоров'я України.
Є сотні підзаконних актів, які це також підтримують.
То я думаю, що цей хід, крок за кроком, йтиме вперед.
І чи це наша команда залишиться, чи буде нова команда,
найважливіше, щоб ми йшли вперед,
підтримували цю політику, яка вже була підтверджена державою.
Було кілька спроб звільнення вас з посади
виконувачки обов’язків здоров’я.
З новою командою ці спроби повторяться?
Ми сподіваємось, що так як
демократичні вибори відбулись в Україні,
буде й інавгурація, яка відбудеться
в кінці наступного місяця, як така
домовленість вже буде,
І тоді новий президент буде
заходити в хід справ держави.
Будуть парламентські вибори, які будуть восени,
в жовтні, і після парламентських виборів,
буде призначений новий склад уряду.
Сподіваємось, що цей спокійний,
стабільний хід, який повинен бути в нашій державі,
так і буде відбуватись.
Ми готові працювати і представляти ті зміни,
які ми зараз робимо, щоб було розуміння.
Бо як ми побачили у декотрих виступах,
можливо, немає до кінця розуміння, що відбувається в охороні здоров'я,
ми готові представляти, співпрацювати з ними, щоб було
розуміння, як воно буде продовжуватись з часом.
Але також охорона здоров'я - це є
під Кабінетом міністрів, під урядом,
президент не має великого впливу
на охорону здоров'я і на ті зміни, які відбуваються.
Але ми хочемо щоби була підтримка від нової команди.
У вас є програма Ihealth,
яка повністю реєстр переходить в онлайн.
Є електронні картки й електронні рецепти.
Можливо в такій сфері ви зійдеться з новою командою?
Ми вже йдемо дуже швидко вперед,
щоби перестрибнути від того, що є папір до електронних карточок.
Але це також є політика нашого уряду,
бо не лише в медицині,
але і багатьох інших сферах, чи є соціальна програми,
чи дуже багато в Міністерстві юстиції вже перейшли
на електронні дані і в електронний спосіб співдії з державою.
Ми могли слідкувати за тим,
скільки потреб є і як воно все відбувається
і дуже важливо воно зменшує ризик корупції.
Ми й Deutsche Welle дуже багато подорожували Україною
і спілкувались з лікарями, які нарешті мають можливість
аробити гроші. Вони відкрили свій ФОП.
Є також українці, які підписали декларацію з лікарями
і мають можливість лікуватись і консультуватись з лікарями безкоштовно,
а рахунок держави. Але є дуже багато критиків реформи.
І для мене теж запитанння і я не розмію, чому так відбувається?
Як ви пояснюєте цю поляризацію суспільства?
Зміна системи охорони здоров'я, фінансування, відбулась лише на первинній ланці,
де, як ви говорите, люди задоволені,
мають своїх сімейних лікарів і мають свої ФОПи,
які мають свою практику, вони вже заробляють більше.
Так само як і ті, які працюють в комунальних закладах,
у них також підвищилась зарплата.
І пацієнти задоволені, бо вони мають дуже чіткий і
гарантований пакет послуг,
які надаються безкоштовно для них
бо вже оплачені через податки.
Там де є нарікання - це там, де ще не відбулася зміна.
Там, де є спеціалісти на рівні поліклінік,
там де є діагностичні тести, або у лікарнях.
Там ми змогли допомогти, щоб було більше ліків
через міжнародні організації закуповуємо вже на 40% більше ліків,
але ще не змінилась система фінансування на тому рівні.
Літом буде програма пілотна- безкоштовна діагностика,
де пацієнти, наші громадяни, які мають направлення від свого сімейного лікаря,
зможуть отримати безкоштовно діагностичні тести у тих закладах,
які підписали договір з Національною службою здоров'я України.
А від наступного року вже у лікарнях на рівні лікарень
і поліклінік, де спеціалізована медицина працює, буде зміна у фінансуванні.
Я думаю, що в наступному році побачимо більше задоволених на цьому рівні.
Але щоб бути відвертими і говорити правду,
у нас є дуже стара інфраструктура,
у нас є дуже мало обладнання у багатьох лікарнях,
і цього не можна за один рік чи за два роки змінити.
Нам потрібно, щоб були інвестиції у наші лікарні,
там де будуть лікуватись наші пацієнти.
В державі немає достатньо коштів, щоб перебудувати всі лікарні України.
Ми тоді будемо наполягати, щоб місцева влада,
де зараз дуже багато податків залишається на місцевому рівні,
щоб вони інвестували в інфраструктуру у своїх лікарнях.
Також щоб були приватні і публічні партнерства,
де інвестиції можуть прийти зовні, з бізнесу,
і щоб ми могли б швидше змінювати інфраструктуру, яка є.
Ну а зарплата лікарів буде залежати від свого директора,
який перебирає лікарню. Від першого січня 2020 року
вже не буде тарифної сітки, вже буде новий договір
з медичним закладом і так само як і на первинній ланці,
ми бачимо зміни у зарплатах, ми сподіваємось, що так буде і у лікарнях.
Міністерство комунікує з тими, хто не задоволений?
Бо критика є і от наприклад, навіть
лікар Комаровський, який зараз в команді новообраного президента
він теж - звинувачує - не звинувачує. говорить, що МОЗ не чує критики.
Кожному щось може не сподобатись. Це правда.
Ми слухаємо наших лікарів і пацієнтів,
і пацієнтські організацій і ми реагуємо на все.
Вперше в країні ми створили
не спускали з гори, з Києва якісь реформи,
а створили консолідацію людей, всіх стейкхолдерів.
Це були і пацієнтські організації, багато з них
зараз працюють в середині МОЗу,
і лікарські асоціації, товариства.
Ми розширювали експертів, щоб якнайширше коло лікарів
були на рівні експертів МОЗу, щоб ми могли розуміти, які у них є потреби.
Ми говоримо і з місцевою владою, щоб було розуміння,
але дуже важливо, щоб критика була конструктивною.
З самого початку, коли ми говорили про первинну ланку, була ідея,
З самого початку, коли ми говорили про первинну ланку, була ідея
Ми поїхали і спілкувались з батьками маленьких дітей
і вони кажуть: "Ми хочемо мати педіатрів, ми не хочемо лише сімейних лікарів.
Дайте нам можливість вибрати педіатра або сімейного лікаря".
Ми їх послухали і ми повернули педіатрів на первинну ланку.
Згадалась думка Володимира Зеленського про швидку і про 39 градусів.
Коли батьки викликають швидку, а вона не приїздить на такі виклики.
Є чіткий список тих випадків,
на які можна викликати екстрену медичну допомогу.
Це є ті речі, які загрожують життю самого пацієнта.
Інші речі - невідкладний стан.
Це треба поспілкуватися, або побачитись з лікарем.
Але це не є екстрена медична допомога.
На жаль, за останні 20 років
наша екстрена медична допомога перетворилась
на первинну ланку на машинах екстреної медичної допомоги.
70% викликів - не екстрені.
Пані Уляно, як ви особисто реагуєте на критику від Богословської. Комаровського?
Як чую цю критику і вона є конструктивною, то ми її беремо до уваги
і йдемо далі і дивимось, чи можлива була
якась помилка, чи ми повинні покращувати
процедури, що вже втілили.
Ви постійно говорити "ми"…
"Ми" - бо ми це є команда.
Це я сама не зробила,
це не якісь реформи Супрун. Це є зміни
і трансформація системи охорони здоров'я, які відбувається командно.
Не лише я і не лише мої заступники.
Це ціле міністерство. Нові інституції, лікарі,
пацієнти, уряд, ВР і
бізнес, який зайшов у Ihealth і в інші системи,
Це є командно і це правильно зроблено.
Вам як жінці в уряді легше спілкуватися з чоловіками чи жінками?
Мені все одно. Для мене гендерна рівність,
чи чоловік чи жінка,
ми спілкуємось як колеги,
маємо повагу одне до одного.
Всі члени уряду насправді так само з повагою
одне до одного завжди спілкуються
і колегіально вирішуємо багато проблем,
які є міжсекторальні.
Але чи можна сказати, що у вас є підтримка?
Ви працюєте вже 3 роки, але ви все ще виконувачка обов'язків,
ще тривають судові тяганини над вами.
До речі, на якому вони етапі?
Потрібна судова реформа, давно вже потрібна.
Я думаю і сподіваюсь, що коли
новий президент буде на місці, то це буде одна з його топ-тем
на порядку денному.
Потрібно швидко це вже змінювати, бо це не лише по мені.
Ми бачимо багато речей, які відбуваються в судовій системі.
Чи це повернення Насірова на посаду,
чи це нещодавно щодо "Приватбанку",
зупинення навіть конкурсу на митницю.
Ви очікуєте, що з новим президентом може закритись
і справа проти вас?
Я думаю, що це справа немає ніякого...
Там по суті нічого немає і все,
відбувається, це є переслідування.
І я думаю, що зараз використовують суди,
щоб і політично, і фінансово переслідувати декотрих членів уряду
і навіть сам уряд.
Я сподіваюсь, що буде розуміння, що відбувається
і будуть правильні рішення на рівні судової системи
в загальному і на рівні президента щодо того.
Пані Уляно, якщо коротко ви задоволені ходом реформ?
Дуже задоволена і не лише я.
Нещодавно у ВООЗ написали публічно,
на їхньому сайті, що вони приємно здивовані тим,
що так швидко йде реформа в Україні,
що зміна фінансування проходить за два роки,
те що в інших країнах за десять років або п'ятнадцять років.
Кажуть часом, що мусять викинути їхні правила,
як робити реформу, і спробують переорієнтуватись.
І хочуть привезти з інших країн міністрів
охорони здоров'я, щоб подивитись,
як ми працюємо, показати їм, що це можливо.